大家好欢迎收听哈修 我昨天才刚从北京落地上海。
咱们在北京呆了差不多两个星期的时间。
哎呦我妈呀 听见上海这个我窗外面打雷的声音了吗？
这还是双层玻璃呢 这声音都能透出来。
感觉好像是一场清喷大雨。
总之呢昨天就是回到了上海。
今天呢就躲进了咱们的这个录音小屋里面。
跟大家捞到一机单口。
昨天我的飞机从北京落地上海的时候。
走出红桥机场 我有一个特别新的感受。
其实在北京呆的这两个星期的时间 我见了不少朋友。
北京这个城市 我给它打的最大的标签就是松尺。
所以说呢 我在见朋友的过程中。
我觉得自己也积累了很多松尺感。
但是当我走出红桥机场的时候 坐进了我打的那辆车。
我看着窗外就觉得说 哎 上海的一切好像都要更亮烫一些。
就整个城市的清晰度好像更高一点。
玻璃呢 也看上去更透亮 灯光好像也更明亮。
甚至是你仔细看那个人。
街上的人感觉清晰度都更高一些。
然后我的车子就开始慢慢的启动。
我看着外面的景色 就总觉得 哇。
这个城市确实是挺精致的。
但是车子开着开着 使上了高架桥之后。
我也感觉到我在北京过去那两星期积累的松尺感。
再一点一点瓦解 信息一挑一挑进来。
又要回到自己生活的正轨 开始安排工作和生活。
然后那一刻我就突然在想说。
哎 那你觉得北京很有松尺感。
我们一天到晚都在讨论松尺感。
松尺感这三字到底代表什么呢？
松尺感是喝茶六弯豆鸟吗？
松尺感是满不在乎吗？
松尺感是此刻老娘累了就想躺下吗？
然后就突然想到了一个故事。
去年我不是去柏林跑马拉松吗？
柏林马拉松其实算是我年轻的时候。
一直在心里种下的一颗种子。
当时我完全没有在认真的练跑步。
但是不知道为什么每次喝多了之后。
都跟朋友说我想去跑柏林马拉松。
以至于去年我其实已经三二七岁高龄。
但是呢 觉得自己无论是前代子。
还是身体还是心灵都已经准备好了。
可以从上海不远万里的飞去柏林。
就为了跑一个马拉松。
每次我跟别人讲这个时候。
别人都觉得不可思议说。
你花那么多钱 机票酒店。
慈善名额也挺贵的。
你过去吃苦跑四十二公里。
我说对 但是由此可知。
如果你万里迢迢的从中国到德国。
这么远的地方
去实现你年轻的时候心里的一个梦想。
你的心态一定不可能是松弛的。
所以说比赛前三天。
我感觉到我的这个肠胃一直就是一个纠结的状态。
只要想到三天后要去跑这个马拉松。
就立刻想要去厕所里面拉肚子。
你紧张就是因为你在乎嘛？
比赛的那天呢柏林的温度还挺热的。
不是特别特别好跑的一个天气。
我在那里坑吃 坑吃 坑吃。
哎呀到了三十公里之后在那咬牙坚持。
坑吃 坑吃 坑吃。
哎呀终于拼到了三十八公里。
坑吃 坑吃 最后冲陷。
结果呢？
不是我预想中可能最最好的一个成绩。
但是我还是满意的。
第二天吃早饭
我们那个酒店里面住着。
从全世界各地来的跑者。
大家都是来跑柏林马拉松的。
因为他离七点很近。
跑完了嘛？
心态也稍微放松了一些。
遇到了一个东北大哥。
我们几个中国人坐在一桌吃早饭。
然后那东北大哥就问我说。
哎 昨天跑怎么样了。
我说还可以 还算满意。
他说
那茅台椒你哪没有。
茅台椒呢？
其实就是欧洲的一个品牌的。
一个跑步吃的这种椒。
主要是补充能量的。
他之所以叫茅台
是他那个名字翻译过来。
很像是茅台
其次呢？
就是他像茅台酒一样。
他挺贵的
但是他是这一次
柏林马拉松的官方用椒。
我说
我都没顾上
我那使劲跑的是几公里。
在那发胶啊？
他说
哎呀？
你真是错过了
那脚老贵了
我拿了好几个
我说
哦
接着大哥问我说
按摩做了吗？
啊？
我说
哪还有按摩呀？
他说
三十几公里那地儿有按摩呀？
你没整上吗？
我说
我我我都没注意到。
他说
我刚好跑那腿酸了。
让那个德国营给我按半天。
老爽了
我当时
有一种
扑痴一笑的感觉
我想说这可能就是传说中的松齿感吧？
当我在那里坑痴坑痴。
闭着眼睛咬牙坚持的时候。
哥去拿了胶
哥还做了按摩
我反而最后没问哥到底是。
多长时间完赛的
但我想说这也许
不是哥的主要目的。
但松齿感到底是什么呢？
也许就是
你在那里拒经会神的。
觉得你的这摊事
就是世界上最重要的事情。
你在内心把自己英雄化了。
我此刻一定要排除万难。
我此刻一定要拒经会神。
我此刻一定要全力以赴的时候。
有人在你旁边做了一个大宝剑。
而你看到他的时候。
我会觉得
你很难不产生一种。
会心一笑的感觉
就是
你可以选择这样生活。
他也可以选择这样生活。
开头稍微有点扯远了。
但是这次不是在北京。
见了不少朋友吗？
有新朋友
有旧朋友
有一些比较松齿的局。
也有一些
稍微紧张一点点的局。
我就想到
前段时间经常有
听友给我留言说
竹子要不要聊一聊。
如何small talk。
有没有一些打开
这些令人紧张的
局面的一些聊天技巧。
因为有的时候可能我们的生活。
难免会遇到这样的境遇。
我新入职一家公司。
我刚认识一圈新朋友。
跟没有那么熟悉的客户吃饭。
参加朋友婚礼
但其实
全场不认识谁
或者说是我作为博主。
经常遇到的一个情况。
就是可能会去参加一些发布会。
或者说是
机为酒会
林林总总的这些
经常在大家脑中
可能浮现出来的
非常上海的这些派对。
不瞒你们说
其实
我觉得
你出入一个
你没有那么熟悉的场合。
咱们就说这个场合。
平时
显少
在你的日常生活中发生。
就像我前面举到的这些例子。
我会觉得在这其中。
大家经常有的一个误解是。
外相的人
会
很天然的觉得
自己如雨得水
只有内相的人
才会在这种场合中觉得非常内耗。
不知道如何该打开一个社交局面。
我在北京的时候
刚好找一个朋友聊天。
其实我跟他也没那么熟。
于是我就问他
我说
你MBTI是什么？
你是内相型人
还是外相型人
然后他说了一句话。
我印象挺深刻的
他说
其实
外相和内相是一个悖论。
我说
什么意思呀？
他说
你不觉得吗？
在社交场合
只有位高权重的人。
只有有话语权的人。
只有有权利的人
可以说自己是内相的人。
其他的人
其实不太有权利说自己是内相的。
我后来仔细思考了一下。
我觉得
除非你
这一场局面
你就是甘愿当一个小透明。
你来这里
你无欲无求
不然我朋友说的这个话。
其实有一番道理
我在从北京回
上海的飞机上面
一边琢磨这件事
我就一边写下来了一些可能。
这些年来
我自己观察出来的一些。
也许可以
拿出来跟大家讨论的一些社交小技巧。
我大概写了五六条。
一会咱们可以一条一条过一遍。
但其实在最前面的时候。
我还是要说明一件事情。
那就是
大家仔细想一想
社交这件事情
它可能本身就是累的。
它可能本身就是一件。
我们需要后天去修炼的本领。
它可能本来就是一个。
当我们
处于陌生的场合之中。
看到
不同位置的人的时候。
需要刻意训练自己有的。
该见到什么人说什么话的一种意识。
甚至说
我的母亲马女士经常跟我说。
她奶奶原来教导她说。
你要当一个大家归秀。
会说话会招待人
是你的一种教养
这个不是你内向外向的问题。
这个是你是否需要获得这种教养。
从小你爸你妈
有没有教你的这么一件事。
它可能有的时候
甚至是一种小的时候。
在家看到自己家的长辈。
如何招待客人的一种耳目染。
它甚至有可能是
足足备备
口口相传下来的一些生活哲学。
所以我觉得
意识到这一点的时候。
大家会不会有一种反。
想开了
放下了
或者开冷的感觉
因为它和你个人没有什么关系。
它和你个人的性格没有什么关系。
它就是像
之前那玩说
幸福是一个可以修炼的能力一样。
我当然读到这句话的时候。
觉得豁然开朗
其实很多事情
它都是可以学习的一种本领。
一种能力
而且我为什么觉得。
这种场合
它势必要累一些
因为如果一个场合里面。
因为你想象
即将面对的这个局。
里面可能会有行业前辈。
可能会有你一直很敬重的人。
但是也有和你平极的一些同事。
私下可能走得近的一些朋友。
或者说有你心仪的对象。
再有可能是
你觉得他可能最近状态。
没有那么好的下属。
他就不是一个私下朋友。
聚在一起搓麻将
摳着脚
刻瓜子
那么一个闲聊局
但凡你在这个局里面。
每一个人的状态不一样。
你累的其中一个很重要的事情。
就是你要判断每一个人。
他分别处于什么样的阶段。
他与你的位置关系是什么样子的。
在这里大家不要说。
那我这样判断是不是很势力。
我觉得这个说法他特别的二元。
在社交场合里面
我们在开口跟一个人说话之前。
势必是要判断
他和你的关系是什么样子的。
因为你履轻了对方和你的关系。
你才可以快速的在大脑里面。
决断一个
你可以跟对方展开的一个谈话风格。
这不是势力
我认为这其实是一种基本的修养。
举个例子
如果站在你前面的。
是一位行业前辈
或者说是你现在公司的领导。
或者老板
再或者说是你要争取的同事。
你觉得你跟他说话的态度。
可以像平时
你跟你朋友说话
一样那么随便吗？
如果过于随便的话。
是不是显得你会比较没有礼貌。
但是如果对方是和你同圈层的人。
比如说是和是你的同辈。
或者说是跟你平级的同事朋友。
那也许你就是可以稍微更放松一点。
不然的话别人反而会觉得你很崩着。
你很紧
甚至觉得你很装逼。
但是如果你此刻面对的是一个你的。
不能说是敌人吧？
但是也许是你需要颈背的人。
他也许是你的同行。
或者说是你们俩在同时争取一个利益。
那你跟他说话的时候。
你确实要有点把门的。
你不能什么都说
因为此刻如果你泄露出来。
不仅是你的秘密
还关乎于你团队
还关乎于你的老板。
但如果此刻
你已经是一个中层或者上层。
你在面对着你的下属。
你们如果在一个稍微轻松一点的环境里面。
其实是更好的
让你去聆听下属
到底有什么真实感受的机会。
但如果这个时候
你可能进入了一个相对。
没有这么复杂的圈子。
哪怕是你进入了一个。
你们因为爱好相思而聚在一起的圈子。
就你们在现实生活中。
没有那么多的交集。
那你也可以说
OK好的
景界可以稍微放下来一点点。
我们大家都可以轻松一点。
因为也许聊得好
我们还能成为朋友。
除了有上述的这些判断。
就我搬到上海之后的经验而言。
因为其实上海这样的社交活动。
还是蛮多的
尤其我的这个工作。
作为一个自媒体的博主。
去见你的客户
因为客户可能有新的产品要发布。
或者客户有新的战略。
需要跟你沟通
你们经常会在一个。
工作属性很强的这样的一个局里面。
很多时候很多朋友会觉得。
这样的局是非常消耗精力的。
甚至一些感情比较充沛的朋友。
会想说
在这样的局里面
我需不需要耍猴
我需不需要
就是给大家讲故事。
我需不需要给大家说段子。
但是在马上开始我们的这个。
我跟大家即将讨论的这些可能。
我总觉得出来的一些小技巧之前。
我再说一句定调的话。
就我算反而觉得
在这样的社交局里面。
温
你知道吗？
就是温开水的那个温。
温是一个特别特别好的一个社交属性词。
其实在这样的应酬场合里面。
你只要拿捏住一个适当的尺度就够了。
因为其实现在的这种社交局跟。
比如说我小时候
有时候会陪我爸妈去的那些社交局。
还有挺大不一样的。
我觉得现在的年轻人不太会。
特别使劲的灌对方喝酒。
好像咱们不喝多了。
咱们今晚不能败把子。
咱们这生意就没法谈。
大多数时刻
其实现在的年轻人还是比较注重。
彼此之间的尺度的。
在上海这个城市更是如此。
所以我觉得
大家不要把这件事情想得压力过大。
因为你在这样的场合里面。
你不需要保持过分的热情。
但是你又不能看上去非常冷淡。
你只要保持一种温吞的状态。
就可以了
好了
那么话不多说
我们就进入
我列下的一些闲聊的小技巧。
或者说是打开一个社交局面的小技巧。
第一个小技巧
作为一个谈话的开始。
无论对方是与你关系亲疏的不一样的人。
其实提问都是一个表示自己礼貌。
我对你充满兴趣
我对你有好感
所以我对你有疑问的这样的一种方式。
但是问什么样的问题。
我觉得大家可以在心里面准备。
大概几个这种比较适合闲聊的。
它不涉及打探对方隐私。
但是又相对简单轻松的话题。
我总结出来这样的话题。
几乎可以对所有人都适用的。
包括你最近吃了什么好吃的餐厅。
你最近点了什么值得推荐的外卖。
尤其是比如说如果你到了一个新的城市。
你可以问对方
比如你到武汉
你说我明天早餐那个酒店不很早。
你推荐我去哪里过早吗？
或者说是点什么好吃的外卖。
最近过暑假了
小孩也放假了
你打算带着他们去哪里旅行。
或者哪怕是没有孩子的人也是。
你今年年假修完了吗？
你去哪里旅行了
你计划去哪里旅行。
最近有没有看什么好看的剧和电影。
或者说是有没有看什么有意思的展览。
书或者杂志
还有哪怕你问说
你是什么星座的
你什么 MBTI的。
这些都没什么问题。
因为这些问题它都非常的烦。
但是我觉得哪一些问题最好不要问。
第一就是情感类的问题。
如果人家不说你最好别去问。
你结婚了吗？
你是单身吗？
你有男朋友吗？
你有孩子吗？
也不要去打探人家的财务状况。
什么你们公司今年怎么样。
有时候我发现
可能不仅是过年时候长辈会问这样的问题。
有的时候在一些社交场合的时候。
一些朋友也会问出这样的问题。
什么你们公司今年那个计修怎么样。
奖金发的多不多
最近做什么投资
我其实觉得这种问题跟钱有关的问题。
也是相对敏感的
除非对方愿意说
还有要回避的就是。
大家都懂的宗教
政治这些问题
就是你就记住
问一些吃喝住行
吃喝拉撒这些
相对表面的生活化的话题。
都没有太大问题
问兴趣爱好也没有什么问题。
比如说喜欢体育的朋友。
最近有没有一些比赛的计划。
你最近每周几练
在练什么东西
这些都非常好
大家可以在心里面准备。
很多这种生活上的。
小的很轻的问题
尤其是在这种
可能今晚上这整个社交场合。
每一个人见面
也就是聊个两三句的这种情况下。
这样的问题就很好用。
因为你不要期待着。
有的时候我们去一个社交场合。
我要跟所有人都成为。
好朋友
很多时候
彼此可能就是你有任务。
你要你在这出现了。
然后我有任务我在这出现了。
然后甚至就说
今晚上咱俩要聊天的主要对象。
不是彼此
但是咱彼此不能干着。
所以就问点这种无关痛养的话题。
没有太大问题
所以大家都记住
什么旅游吃喝运动。
这些都是很好的话题。
这是我想分享的第一个小技巧。
第二个小技巧
就是当然你问的这些问题。
你最好自己也有一个回答。
别人问说你呢？
你可以就是轻巧的回答一下。
就除了回答这些
跟生活皮毛有关的问题之外。
如果说你们今天是坐下来要吃个饭。
OK那就是几个可能没有那么熟的人。
要展开一个稍微
时间长一点的对话的时候。
为了比较顺利的暖场。
你其实可以准备
一两个比较轻松好笑的。
关于你的小故事
关于你的或者是你的观察都可以。
但是这个故事
最好不要是炫耀自己的事情。
所以就是可能说一些。
你记得观察会比较合适一些。
我举个例子
比如咱们这期单口的开场。
我就说了一个小观察。
就我就说了一个
为什么我觉得北京可能感觉更松弛。
到底这个松弛是由什么构成的。
然后顺道的讲了一个去年去。
柏林跑马拉松遇到这东北大哥。
我觉得他很松弛的故事。
再比如说
我随便瞎说
就这次我在北京的时候。
我觉得北京另外一个很松弛的表现。
就是你知道北京大妈跟上海大妈。
或者上海也不叫大妈。
上海的阿尼亚之间区别也很大。
上海的奶奶有很多真的是穿戴很精致的。
他无论今天是去买菜。
还是约朋友去跳广场舞。
经常奶奶
那个耳朵上是会戴一个金耳环。
然后手上戴一个金手镯。
还戴一个小项链
然后涂点口红
我奶奶也是我奶奶杭州人。
就是在他很长的这个时间里面。
他经常就是一个很精致的一个老太太。
但是北京的大妈呢？
北京大妈是有一种什么状态。
就有一天我在那长安公园里跑步。
跑着跑着呢？
就经过了一个大妈。
他坐在一个公园的堂椅上面。
在那玩刀
我真的
我看到那个场景的时候。
我觉得特别荒诞
他手里面有两个
就真的是刀
就小刀 你知道吗？
就小李飞刀的那种刀。
就差不多这么长一把吧？
然后他在手里面在那转刀。
就同时在转两把刀。
我就想说
这个之前看过老年人转核桃。
练习自己的这个指力吧？
经常就说这个手指比较灵活。
或者握力比较好的人。
头脑也比较清晰
但是
我都没想到什么时候北京已经升级成。
大妈跟那玩刀了
我想说
大妈真的很狠
然后我经过他的表情非常淡定。
我跑过去的时候
我就真的想扑吃一下。
我真的觉得这个非常代表。
北京这座城市的一种气质。
你真的很难看到
上海阿尿在靖安公园里面玩刀。
再比如说呢？
你也可以分享自己的一些糗事嘛？
我前几天就是
我前几天约了一个。
我还是挺喜欢的一位同行。
我很尊重他
我一直觉得他做产品做得非常好。
就是一个产品小天才。
下手一向是快很准。
我那天就约他一起出来吃了个饭。
因为
其实我觉得他在行业那里还挺神秘的。
也很少听到他发声。
所以我那天就是还挺期待。
挺兴奋能和他坐下来吃饭的。
我打扮得挺漂亮的。
然后穿了一双
很漂亮的一双平底鞋。
然后我俩约在一家。
也是挺精致的一个海鲜餐厅里面。
然后前面都聊得特好。
觉得跟对方聊得也挺投缘的。
就我那双鞋下面
贴了一个防滑的一个贴。
因为它是一双新鞋。
但是有的时候新鞋的防滑贴。
就是很滑
然后我们吃饭的那个餐厅。
又是大理石的地面。
于是我在他面前
活生生的
就这样
屁股着地摔了一个。
接接实实的大屁堆。
就我那个屁堆摔到。
我等等就从大理石的台阶上面摔了。
就都快把我给摔傻了。
然后就有两个大汉过来扶我。
当时给我气的
就是你这样
你在一个你还是挺尊重的一个同行前面。
然后你也挺喜欢人家的。
你希望给人留下一毫的印象。
结果你蹲蹲蹲蹲
你穿着一双鞋
你挺嘚瑟
今天打不挺漂亮的。
在别人面前摔一大屁堆。
我就跟人家说
我告诉你
你今天要是敢把这件事说出去。
咱俩就掰面
当然现在我自己说出来了。
但就是我觉得
你可以准备几件这种。
自己特别特别糗的事。
或者是比较有趣的观察。
如果你觉得这个社交场合。
有机会说
你可以三言两语
或亲或众的把那个描述出来。
因为其实有的时候。
你可以观察这个这个谈话。
我觉得一个好的谈话呢？
是又干又湿的
什么是湿呢？
湿就是相对比较感受的。
比较情感的
比较有故事情节的这样的。
一种谈话方向
干呢其实就是会相对于。
更理性一些
更偏方法论总结
更偏干货一类的
如果一晚上都很干。
其实挺烧脑的
总需要一些
比较湿的东西进来点缀。
我觉得平时我们准备的这些故事。
就是一些
湿润的海绵小蛋糕。
当然就是大家注意。
就这种故事啊？
我建议不要太长
就大概可能能控制在。
两分钟以内
甚至就说你心里面有可长。
或者可短的版本
比如说我前面说那公园。
大妈玩刀的那个
如果你觉得场合合适。
你可以对它进行细节的。
许举如生的描述
但如果你觉得场合不合适。
你也可以三言两语。
说完比如说
北京人很松弛的
前两天我去长安公园跑步。
看见那个
那群健身的大爷大妈。
不仅玩槓铃
还有一个大妈跟那玩刀。
第三个小技巧就是。
如果你遇到了你真正喜欢。
和欣赏的人
有两个方法
可以让你很自然的接近他们。
第一个方法就是向他们提问。
你知道有的时候夸人这件事。
还是蛮需要技巧的。
夸的不好
就容易尴尬
但是有一个很稳的做法。
就是如果你不知道怎么夸人。
你的赞美其实可以完美的。
通过提问的方式来达成。
举个例子
如果我见到鲁玉老师。
我可能会问我说
鲁玉老师我真心的求问。
您到底是怎么做到。
如此高密度的输出。
这么高质量的长时间的采访。
这是我真心的一个疑问。
而且其实你也可以通过这个提问。
听出来
我对于鲁玉老师的养木之情。
但是你的这个话
其实可以通过提问的方式来达到。
或者说如果你遇到一个。
比如说很有毅力的人。
你与其问他说
哎呀 你跑步怎么这么有毅力。
你可以问他说
请问你到底是怎么？
在这么繁忙的作息里面。
去插入训练的时间的。
我想学习一下
如果你遇到一个
比如说很会投资
或者是很会做内容的人。
比如说是这个
啪啪酱
那你就可以问他说。
我非常佩服你的一点。
就是无论你是二十多岁的状态。
还是三十多岁的状态。
你一直都是舆论的先锋。
请问你是怎么做到。
这么敏锐的去捕捉。
这个时代的温度
或者是舆论的升调的。
如果我遇到很会做投资的人。
你也可以问他说
你可以保持这么长时间。
获得如此稳定的正向收益。
如果总结一个
帮助你穿越周期的技巧。
它是什么？
就是你看
你可以把你的赞美。
其实也是你真心的疑问。
你把两者结合在一起。
你即可能得到一个答案。
同时你也表达了自己的赞美。
而且很多时候我觉得。
咱们换位思考一下。
比如说
要接收赞美的这个人。
是你自己
如果对方就是很干很干的夸。
你说
举个例子
他说
哎呀竹子
我觉得你真的是状态好好。
你保养的好好
我会感到高兴
但其实你除了说
谢谢
你也说不出来什么别的。
对不对
但如果有人真的问说。
竹子
你看上去状态好好。
你觉得运动
吃得干净
睡得好
这三个哪个更重要的时候。
你会觉得说
咱俩的画匣子也打开了。
不是你夸完我之后。
咱俩就在那儿愣着扎你扔。
对吧？
所以说这个是一个。
关于赞美的技巧
我想说关于赞美
还有一个方法
就是你不是不能正面赞美。
如果你选择正面赞美的话。
其实可以不说一些很大的话。
你可以去夸对方
做的好的一些细节。
比如说
就你觉得对方
今天的穿搭很漂亮。
你可以说
哎
我觉得今天的这个。
丝巾是点睛之比
你从哪找来的这么漂亮的小丝巾。
而你看你这丝巾扣。
哎
我都没有注意到这个丝巾扣。
可以这么别
因为你不知道
可能这人
他真的是在家里准备了半天。
他发现今天穿这身衣服有点平淡。
但是哎
这个丝巾是一个点睛之比。
他过来了
但可能大家都觉得说。
他造型整体不错
他一直都挺会穿的。
但是你是那个看出来了。
他的丝巾是点睛之比的这个人。
所以说
在细节上的赞美有的时候。
可能会夸到对方的心里。
再比如说
你甚至可以把这个夸。
夸得再调皮一点
举个例子
如果是我遇到一些同行。
我觉得同行的这个创作能力。
非常的强
我可能会说
你怎么做到这么高频率。
更新
每个视频质量都那么高的。
我简直是太嫉妒了。
就是
你说你是真心的嫉妒吗？
当然你要注意你的口吻。
你不能说
我真的是太嫉妒
这么说也没问题
你不能说
我真的是太嫉妒了。
不对
这么说也没问题
好
这话怎么说
应该都问题不大
反正就说
你知道你是用比较夸张的口吻。
你
但是你最终其实是在赞美对方的。
而且你确实是真心的赞美。
我觉得这里面还有一个地方。
就是你一定要发自真心。
如果你觉得对方这个人。
你没什么想赞美的地方。
那你就不用赞美他。
你不用非得跟他搞关系。
而去使出这一套了。
但是确实我会觉得。
我们比如遇到的一些行业前辈。
或者我们想从他身上吸取经验的人。
他身上肯定是能找到。
你想去问的一些问题。
或者你想去赞美的一些细节的。
然后其次我想在这里再多说一句。
我觉得在这种较为陌生的场合。
就算你没赞美好
你赞美有点尴尬
就是你对方你赞美完了。
你说那个鲁鱼老师。
我真的是觉得您就是时代英雄。
那你一定要留在牌桌上。
您太伟大了
就比如说你就是就调子。
夸得特别高
然后鲁鱼老师盯着你说。
好
谢谢
然后你俩不要说什么？
说那鲁鱼老师
我先去拿一小面包吃。
然后鲁鱼老师好
好一会回见
做很有礼貌
我觉得这也没问题。
就是大家不要吝嗇赞美。
我刚才只说可以赞美。
可以这样去赞美
但其实只要是赞美。
不太会有什么问题。
但在这样的场合里面。
不要轻易吐槽
不要在陌生人面前轻易吐槽。
哪怕是你吐槽说
哎呦这地儿吃的不怎么样啊？
或者说
哎呦这客户怎么选。
失败这么一个地儿。
文字好多呀？
或者是跟没有那么熟的人说。
哎你知道谁是谁吗？
哎呦他特别难搞
不要
就是不要
就首先啊我自己有一个悖论。
我其实觉得
就算是跟你最好的朋友。
你也要小心
就不要经常的吐槽。
起码我是这么判断一个人的。
如果说这个人
每次我们见面的时候。
他总是充满了对于这个世界。
这个世界的运行方式。
对他身边的关系的一些。
种种不满和吐槽
且他经常吐槽的人是我认为。
比如说这个人他仍然在帮你。
或者说这个人
他是你的客户
他是给你钱的人
那我会在心里有点害怕。
我走了之后
这个人会不会像别的人吐槽我。
所以吐槽
挺容易暴露一个人的局限性的。
我们可以写日记
在日记里面你自己想骂谁骂谁。
但是一旦你张口
你在评论外界关系的时候。
我们可以肆意的赞美。
我们也可以进行中性的评论。
但是但凡是负面的评论。
我都觉得大家要稍稍注意一些。
这是第三点
第四点就是
前面说了三个度
我觉得第四个是一个don't。
第四个don't就是。
不要说大话
不要吹嘘自己
尤其是我觉得在一个新人。
当你进入一个你觉得。
满场都是比我资深的。
前辈的这么一个局里的时候。
或者就是说
我对这个局感觉到有点陌生。
有点不舒适的时候。
人有的时候会下意识的去保护自己。
就是我也没那么差。
就是我也见过
我也吃过
我也看过
我也做过
但是有的时候会有一点点。
夸张的成分在里面。
尤其是在当你面对。
和你圈层不一样的人的时候。
如果对方说了什么事情。
或者说
他们在一起说了什么事情。
你觉得很插不上话。
你觉得好像此刻必须得。
跟着走一走
也跟着吹嘘一下
或者也跟着说一些。
自己可能不会真的去做的事情。
才好像觉得我融入了的时候。
其实我觉得不要这样。
因为你没做过的事情。
或者就说
你没有再过这样的生活。
而你说出了一些话的时候。
是很容易露馅的
举个例子
现在刚好是夏天
可能你去了一个局。
大家都在聊说
夏天去哪里度假
有的人说我们夏天去巴黎岛。
有的人说我们夏天去新西兰。
有的人说
我们夏天去欧洲
但其实你夏天
没有任何度假的计划。
那这时候
其实你就听他们说就好了。
你可以听他们说
你也可以提问
你可以说
真的
新西兰可以去哪玩。
是不是南半球
这时候挺凉快的
巴黎岛还有适合小孩的夏令营。
我记一下
下次我们也可以参加。
就是你不必非要
说你自己也得干什么？
甚至我其实很欣赏一种情况。
就是我没有度假计划。
我可能就是在上海待着。
我就大大方方地说。
我说我们没有度假计划。
我们可能去趟倾谱。
你不知道倾谱是上海的南法吗？
我给你推荐几个倾谱的地方。
下次你都不用去南法。
你直接去倾谱就行了。
So funny。
没有任何问题好吗？
总体来说
我觉得城市
是一个挺重要的社交品格。
你不要觉得说
OK
我身边的这些人
都比我厉害很多
我就不能承认
我现在的生活状态是什么样的。
举个例子
就前段时间
我读到一个文章
他讲的是很早以前。
台湾的一个综艺咖。
他是黑社会出来的一个女生。
叫做丫头
她的大名好像叫詹子晴。
我不知道你们知不知道这个名字。
有一点点时代的烙印。
不知道可以去查一查。
她大概就15、16岁。
就开始上黑社会了。
然后她在节目里面。
就经常很大方的说。
我们家很穷
我妈妈就是单亲妈妈。
然后从小要拉筹
我跟我弟弟
从小我们就是要住什么鬼屋。
张狼屋老鼠屋
所以我最大的志向。
就是来赚钱
我上这些通告
就是为了赚钱
我就是要赚钱
攒够了钱
买我的第一套房子。
他从来都不避讳
自己的生活状况
此时此刻是很糟糕的。
他从来都不避讳
他要告诉别人
就我不知道你们是谁。
也许你们是富二代。
也许你们是不缺钱的人。
但是我
丫头
我就是一天要打三分工。
我的世界里面
我现在的首要目标。
就是要赚钱
我读到那篇文章
让我觉得非常触动的一点是。
后面他真的在自己。
二十出头的时候
赚够了钱
就是他这个很会攒钱的女孩。
就是每一个月收入到了。
有一笔固定存款的钱。
这个钱是无论如何。
他都不会花
他一定会存进来的。
而终有一天
他攒够了首富的时候。
我有读到
当然不知道是真的假的。
他的第一套房
是吴宗憲陪他一起去看的。
就是吴宗憲觉得这个小女孩。
非常的努力
非常的勤奋
怕他受骗
所以说就会陪着他。
去看他的第一套房。
而现在的丫头
你们可以去查一查。
他已经是一个连续创业者。
他是一个很成功的。
一个女企业家了
甚至是他合伙的这个公司。
我有点不太记得
好像是一个消费品公司。
甚至冠名了
小S最新的综艺节目。
跨越成为了
可以去赞助小S节目的资方。
这一切背后
其实有一种力量
就是我很诚实
我对于我的生活境遇。
非常诚实
你们也许
已经到了一个人生阶段。
可以去这儿度假
去那儿滑雪
但是我就是要留在上海。
努力工作
其实你们知道
就很多时候
哎
我其实也不太喜欢。
用大佬这个词啊？
逮牢
就是这词是从
那港片里出来的
对不对
逮牢
逮牢们其实很喜欢。
勤奋的年轻人
就如果你展现出来了。
你是一个聪明勤奋的年轻人。
你此刻也许
面临着生活的泥沼。
但你从来没有放弃过。
试着要去爬出来
你惊惊夜夜
勤勤啃啃
你不偷不抢
这样的人多好啊？
谁不想帮这样的年轻人啊？
所以就说
不要说打话
不要吹吹自己
越是在这种
让你觉得
有一点点胆怯的社交场合。
越要实事求是
那也许之中你会问说。
诸子
但是有一句话是
fake it until you make it。
你看那之前的那个俄罗斯名媛。
不就靠着
穿一身名牌
把自己
装得像一个有钱人。
成功打入了
纽约的上层社会吗？
可是我想说的是
那你看他现在在哪啊？
他现在不是在看搜索里面吗？
他现在不是在监狱里面吗？
起码在我
见过的
积累的这个社会经验里面。
我觉得你
很难把自己装成
一个自己不是的人。
尤其是通过这些表面的措施。
就是我其实明明没什么钱。
但我把我的钱都花在。
去买这个名牌包名牌表。
穿得很高级
首先我觉得你把自己。
收拾得很得体
也是一种修养
但这个得体不需要非要通过很多。
看上去很贵的东西去堆器。
如果你本身就是一个。
赚十万块钱
年薪的人
你把你所有钱都花了。
去买这些东西
他也是一个名不符实的事情。
对不对
如果你说你穿成这样。
你真的混进了所谓的。
你想进去的圈子
那人家接下来说
好吧？
那咱们订个机票
咱们去法国滑雪吧？
我们继续再打肿脸冲胖子吗？
我们到底要装到哪一步呢？
就这事
反而我觉得挺难受的。
但是
fake it until you make it。
我觉得你的内在核心。
是可以装的
比如说
我原来就是一个
不敢在公众演讲的人。
但是我给我自己洗脑了。
我今天
就是要脉开第一步。
我今天的目标就是。
我写了一稿子
我就算上台
我就把这稿子给念出来。
我不需要急性发挥。
就把它念出来
就是一种胜利
你骗过自己的大脑。
告诉自己
我可以做到这件事。
完全没有问题
我们今天谈论的一切。
都可以用
fake it until you make it。
我不是一个很会社交的人。
其实我在这种场合是很尴尬的。
但是今天我听竹子。
我们一起聊完
我觉得有一些东西挺实用的。
我可以拿来用
我今天给我自己的指令。
就是我看上去
不要当一个很胆怯的人。
不要当一个
不敢开口说话
不敢开口提问的人。
我今天要卖出第一步。
所以这个就是咱们说的这个。
第四点
第五点
第五点算是对第四点的一个延续。
就是如果你在一个。
认知都高于你的局里面。
比如今儿一个饭局。
然后这饭局里面
都是一些行业前辈。
然后你就是这个小白。
你作为小白出现的。
就说很多的小白
就包括我自己
都会觉得说
我得表现
我得为我自己争取。
我怎么着也得说一两个金句吧？
但其实我现在觉得。
在这种局里面
你最好的身份是主持人。
话不用特别多的那种主持人。
因为如果当场做这几位逮捞。
他们彼此之间
一定是会有一些隐隐的竞争。
或者是大家都有表达欲的。
其实此刻你就应该穿真隐线。
让这些前辈们去表达。
让前辈们去彻底释放。
他们彼此之间这种。
有一些微妙的竞争关系。
你就当话隐子
让前辈去表达
然后你就捧根就行了。
你不需要去当那个主角。
而且在这个场合里面。
你也不是那个主角。
其实在这种场合里面。
与其说你一定要发表什么惊人的言论。
不如说你回到主持人的位置里面。
你问出几个在点上的问题。
你知道就是还是回到咱们前面说的。
让前辈对你印象深刻的。
不是你在那发表了什么真知灼见。
而是你问了前辈
可能一个掏心窝子。
处到他心窝子里的问题。
甚至有的时候
火候得你来掌握
但可能犯过半寸之后。
有一些问题
哪怕带有这一些挑衅都可以。
举个例子
前段时间也是和几个。
来自不同行业的前辈吃饭。
然后其中在这个饭局上面。
有人就抛出了这个问题。
这个问题其实有点老生常谈。
但是这个问题又被包装得挺合适的。
一个人就问另外一个人说。
您看您作为行业前辈。
投了这么多成功的企业。
而且一直在跨领域。
但是为什么在您的投资履历里面。
女性创始人这么少。
其实这个问题
它是烧带挑衅的
但是因为提问者本人。
也是一位女性创始人。
先不管他们日后会不会发生。
任何业务上的往来。
但是你想一个人敢把自己。
抛到这样的环境里面。
提出一个稍微有一点点扎心的问题。
这样的问题有的时候。
可能会让背提问方。
思考一段时间
回味一点点
但是我觉得
提稍微挑衅一点点的问题。
可能适合稍微有经验一点的选手。
总之大家记住了
我觉得我的第五条建议。
就是如果你在一个。
都是前辈的局里面。
很多时候你就shut up。
把自己的ego收回来。
做一个好的话
没那么多
但是可以做到
穿真 引线 捧格。
作用的主持人就可以了。
如果你能做到这一点。
其实就是一个
很好的修养的表现。
最后一条呢？
其实我觉得最后一条。
有的时候超过了
前面几条的重要性。
无论你会不会说话。
无论你会不会讲笑话。
会不会讲自己的观察。
会不会提问
等等
你前面都可以说我不会。
我都拿你也不好
我不做
但是你都可以把最后一条。
给做好
这个最后一条就是。
这个经验我觉得
无论你拿到一个
陌生的饭局
一个建客户的场合。
还是说
哪怕是你约会自己喜欢的人。
都全部通用
就是我们跟别人说话。
一定要挺直了腰板。
眼睛紧紧有神的
大胆的看着对方的眼睛。
在这里让我再挺直。
一条我的腰板
并且面带微笑
然后这样
直勾勾的可以看着对方。
看着对方的眼睛
别看着对方的嘴
或者看着对方的耳朵。
别人可能会觉得你邪事。
无论对方是谁
无论对方是你敬畏的人。
还是跟你同籍的人。
还是是你的下属
还是你喜欢的人
你心动的人
你就记住
你回家可以不练任何事情。
你对着镜子就练这一件事。
你练你的仪表
把你的胸停起来
把你的背指起来
然后面带微笑
很友好的看着对方。
你看着对方的眼睛。
就代表你在听他说的话。
你对他表示好奇
你对他有好感
而且你一旦展现出来了。
这样的身体语言
无论你们是初次见面。
还是说你们即将有一个生谈。
还是怎么样
这样的身体语言
都可以表现出来
你的内核是比较稳定的钱。
你对着对方有一个。
不卑不亢的态度
其实你知道
我最佩服的一类人就是。
他真的是无论面对谁。
无论在他面前的对象是。
奥巴马
还是邻居家的小孩。
他都能展现出
像我们刚才前面描述的这种。
对对方充满了友好。
但是有尊重的表情和态度。
如果你能传达出这样的气质。
不用过得的言语
都可以能让对方感受到。
其实你是一个内核很稳定的人。
而且有的时候
我们也不用笑得太夸张。
但是无论对方说点什么的时候。
你可以抱以微笑
哦 是这样啊？
哦 明白了
哦 学到了
嗯 好的
我回去也可以思考一下。
给予一些淡淡的回应。
有的时候我经常会想这句话。
就是爱笑的女孩
运气都不会太差
其实爱笑的男孩
应该也是同理吧？
因为微笑真的就是一个。
非常非常有魔力的事情。
你但凡看到一个人。
对你说的话抱以微笑的神情。
你会不自觉的
就会对这个人产生好感。
且我觉得有的时候。
都出不上是
我们一定要为对方留下好感。
我觉得很多时候
这仅仅是为了体现。
你有一个比较好的修养。
行 差不多把我在飞机上。
总结的这六条都说完了。
还有什么样
其实我觉得在这里面。
最重要的就是我在。
前面开头的时候
跟大家说的这个心态问题。
就是我们一定要觉得。
拥有社交技巧
知道如何Hold住一场对话。
它跟你的性格表现如何。
跟你的个人成色
跟你的内相还是外相。
不相关
这是一项可以修炼的技能。
而我希望我今天
就跟大家聊的这些。
大家不要觉得说
它就是什么金玉良言。
不是
我觉得这些都仅仅是从我的。
个人经验中
总结出来一些对我试用的东西。
有可能你
听了之后你还觉得说。
对你不一定适用
没关系
重要的是
今天咱俩在这儿聊完之后。
你可以留心这件事情。
你日后就可以
在实践中总结你自己的技巧。
慢慢慢慢的
在一个一个陌生的场合。
你觉得你一次一次。
突破了自己之后
就会有一种
其实我没那么怕了的感觉。
它真的就跟游戏通关是一样的。
然后我就会变成一个。
不再害怕这种
有一点尴尬的
塑胶场合的人
OK
那这一期害羞就是这样了。
非常的希望这一期。
对话
对咱们彼此都有一点帮助。
那我们下期再见喽。
拜拜